[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we have
more
on this morning's joint advisory from
the cdc and the fda
calling for the johnson and johnson
vaccine to be temporarily
shelved in the united states this
vaccine has already been given to 6.8
million americans
and now investigators are looking into
six cases of blood clots
all in women all under the age of 48 who
receive that vaccine
cbs news medical contributor david agus
joins us now
dr agus good morning to you it's
concerning that the fda and the cdc are
making this recommendation ahead of an
advisory meeting tomorrow rather than
just wait for the meeting suggest they
think there's something urgent here
yeah certainly i i think everyone is
upset here is that there's a similar
vaccine astrazeneca that's also we call
an
adenovirus vaccine where blood clots
were seen also
in really small numbers and so when
you're seeing it with two different
vaccines that have some similarity
we get really worried and so tomorrow
morning there'll be an advisory meaning
we'll review these six cases and see
whether they think they are related to
the vaccine or not and what to do
the hope is we could develop a plan to
prevent these from happening
6.8 million americans already have this
vaccine i think everyone at the table a
lot of people watching right now know
somebody who has it
how soon after getting it might you see
these concerning symptoms
so all of the cases happen six to 13
days
after the vaccine and they noted pain in
the abdomen
or pain headache and that caused them to
go to the hospital
five of the six were treated efficiently
were treated differently than the
average blood clot because
here platelet counts are down and you
have to give a special drug that
reverses it
and unfortunately one of the patients
has died from the blood clot
how worried should you be if you have
the j and j vaccine
i'd be a little freaked out right now if
i had gotten j j yeah but
how were i know you keep saying that and
all the experts say it's extremely rare
but
we keep hearing these drumbeat of
stories about j and j so if you've had
it
how worried should you be
well listen you have to monitor yourself
and if you have
any symptoms where you have pain and
it's unexplainable go to an emergency
room right away
and doctors around the country are now
aware of this and they know how to treat
it
so the key is you know listen to your
body and if you start to feel
pain somewhere and you know or swelling
somewhere you need to go in to the
doctor and be evaluated it's
easy to treat once we've identified it
but
yeah i mean listen it's horrible um
absolutely
horrible i wish that hadn't happened
it's going to put a
wrench in what's going on with the
vaccines all of the vaccines and we need
to figure this out and develop a
national plan
to move forward david and we want to
emphasize again it's it's six cases out
of 6.8 million doses that have been
administered
but are is what you're saying you said
it the symptoms developed what six to 13
days
afterwards does that mean that if you
have passed like two weeks
from getting the vaccine you are
probably clear
that's a great point yeah so what we
know i mean at least from this and the
astrazeneca if you're past two weeks you
are clear
and you know it's not probably going to
happen then
if you're worried about anything your
doctor can check a blood test
and look if your platelet counts are
lower look for a particular type of
antibody that's associated with this
so there is a blood clot a blood test
they can look for but i would only do so
if you had symptoms that are worried
does it affect women more than men
yes it's only women all six yes in this
case but
is that is that how it goes always women
more than men
the astrazeneca one it's majority women
and it seems to be associated because
women are more susceptible to this type
of blood clotting
but it's not exclusively so there are
some men in europe
that have been seen but in the united
states to date it's only women
and women who are under the age of 50 so
pre-menopausal women
david we do have to go but i want to
point out that the pfizer and moderna
vaccine are made of a different
technology different platform
and so far anyway and you correct me if
i'm wrong these concerns have not been
brought up in relation to that platform
no there have been hundreds of millions
of fisher modernity with none of this
scene
and it appears to be related to the
adenovirus what we call the carrier